bonsoir à vous Erwan balano bonsoir
Toute main tendu et bonne apprente toute
main tendue doit être considérée
déclaration de François Bayrou le
président du MoDem votre formation
politique il fallait accepter l'idée
d'une médiation proposée par Laurent
Berger de secrétaire général de la CFDT
quand on est dans une situation comme
dans laquelle elle pays en réalité de
tension d'incompréhension parce que je
crois qu'il y a beaucoup
d'incompréhensions il me semble que
c'est important de dialoguer d'écouter
et puis aussi d'entendre et donc de de
faire ce travail de remettre tout le
monde autour de la table et de se
remettre au travail sur ce qui peut être
travaillé et c'est important de
dialoguer sèchement retoqué par Olivier
véranstière pas besoin de médiation pour
parler rétorquer le porte-para le
gouvernement franchement on parle comme
ça j'ai eu l'impression alors j'ai eu
l'impression moi qu'il a dit pas besoin
de médiateur médiateur voilà alors ça
change un peu les choses parce que c'est
qu'il y avait une proposition d'un
médiateur ne pas vouloir de médiateur ça
peut quand même vouloir dire qu'on a
besoin de faire de la médiation en tout
cas nous au groupe modem on est très
déterminé à pousser cette idée de
remettre tout le monde autour de la
table bon en attendant il y a eu la
proposition d'Elizabeth borne qui invite
l'interdicale en début de semaine mais
pour se dire quoi au juste je pense
qu'il y a un certain nombre vous avez vu
comment ça bloque oui mais ça va
continuer à bloquer si tout ce monde ne
se parle pas donc c'est un premier pas
et maintenant il faut il faut mettre un
certain nombre de sujets sur la table et
il y a des sujets sur lesquels je pense
on peut avoir des convergences avec des
organisations syndicales par exemple les
conditions de travail les conduit la
question du partage de la valeur
notre pays a réussi à traverser deux
crises importantes en préservant le
modèle enfin le l'économie fonctionne
plus ou moins plutôt bien on voit que le
taux de chômage descend et les Français
le sentent et les Français ont besoin de
d'un sentiment de justice sociale et de
justice fiscale et ça c'est des sujets
sur lesquels je pense on peut on peut
largement avancer oui mais pourtant le
secrétaire général de toujours lui
Laurent Berger veut parler des 64 ans il
ne veut pas de cette borne c'est
toujours la même position depuis le
départ il veut en parler chez Elisabeth
borne
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce qui se
passe parlons-en puisque dans le texte
qui sort de la CMP il y a la clause d'or
voyou la cloche de voyeur en réalité
2000 en 2027 on sera à 63 ans et 3 mois
donc est toujours avec ses 43 années de
43 annuités
sur cette clause de voyeur
c'est déjà un point sur lequel on peut
négocier donc il y a des sujets il faut
il faut travailler mais gardons le cap
quand même de cette d'une partie de la
réforme d'une grande partie de la
réforme sur la question des équilibres
financiers moi ça m'enchante pas de
faire une réforme où on dit aux gens qui
va falloir travailler plus mais ça
m'enchanterait encore moins de voir
notre système s'écrouler parce que on ne
serait pas capable de supporter la dette
qu'elle génère tout le monde est fatigué
épuisé est-ce que vous réalisez ça en
fait ah mais moi je le réalise
et je suis entièrement d'accord il y a
un climat de violence de tension qu'il
faut vraiment apaiser donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut se mettre autour de la table
et je l'ai dit en préambule c'est
écouter et entendre parce que si on ne
fait écouter on ne va pas avancer donc
il faut aussi peut-être qu'il y a un
certain nombre d'inflexion et moi je
pense vraiment aux inflexions de justice
sociale de justice fixe fiscale parce
qu'on a des enjeux énormes pour notre
pays qui qui sont encore en suspens je
pense à la santé je pense à l'éducation
et je pense à la transition écologique
tout le monde devait fatigué et pendant
ce temps le président de la République
qui veut se réforme s'exprime dans Pif
je sais pas quel est le gadget dans
l'histoire mais sur la conception de la
politique la meilleure manière d'y
arriver c'est de se faire sa propre idée
des choses et de ne pas dépendre des
parties des uns et des autres ça tombe
mal c'est interview je pense qu'elle a
été faite il y a un bon moment moins un
mois il y a un mois bon plutôt déjà dans
la dans la bagarre on pas reprocher non
plus au président de s'adresser à tous
les types de public et en particulier à
la jeunesse bon c'est logique qu'il
explique peut-être sa conception de la
politique aux jeunes et aussi aux très
jeunes vous savez nous on va dans les
écoles on essaie de jamais faire de
politique quand on va dans les écoles
mais on leur parle de ce qu'est la vie
ensemble commun ce que c'est un
engagement politique et pourquoi parfois
c'est bien que les gens s'engagent dans
les autres ce soir va pour pif quoi oui
bon moi j'essaye de pas j'essaye de ne
pas avoir des polémiques à tous les
coins de rue non voilà non autre chose
le président demain se déplace dans les
Hautes-Alpes pour présenter le plan o du
gouvernement qui est un sujet
fondamental finalement c'est avec ce qui
s'est passé dans les Deux-Sèvres c'est
sur les sols la même sujet vous avez la
sensation que il faudrait peut-être
d'abord apurer cette réforme des retrait
d'avant de passer à autre chose c'est
très compliqué ensuite d'être audible
sur des sujets aussi fondamentaux c'est
c'est vrai que c'est un sujet qu'on peut
se poser de stratégie ou de conduite de
l'action publique en ce moment enfin on
a quand même quelques sujets qui restent
des sujets importants pour pour nos
économies pour nos agriculteurs pour la
vie en France et à tous suspendre parce
que on n'a pas fini de travailler sur
les retraites je pense que ça serait une
erreur mais c'est vrai et je le conçois
particulièrement enfin je suis
entièrement d'accord avec vous c'est pas
facile en ce moment de mener un certain
nombre d'actions et de et de décision
audibles sur les autres sujets Erwan
Balan il y a eu cette dixième journée
hier avec une participation en baisse
moins de grévistes nettement moins de
grévistes vous diriez quoi du bien une
forme de de lassitude non j'ai enfin
j'ai l'impression que les Français
restent quand même assez mobilisés faut
pas se cacher les choses il y a des
inquiétudes et elles sont toujours là il
faut il faut les prendre en compte et il
faut apporter un certain nombre de
réponses
je pense que le sujet de la retraite est
un sujet évidemment qui préoccupe
particulièrement les Français mais il y
a d'autres sujets qui qui sont des
sources d'inquiétude et peut-être tout
ça ce agglomération de ces sujets là et
notre rôle c'est je le redis dialoguer
écouter vous vous êtes vice-président de
la commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nationale il y aura l'audition la
semaine prochaine mercredi de Gérald
Darmanin sur les questions du maintien
de l'orgue il y a toute la polémique
autour de ce qui s'est passé autour des
des bassines
il y a un problème de moteur moi je sais
pas s'il y a un problème de maintien de
l'or mais il y a un problème de violence
dans notre pays ça c'est sûr et et de de
ce sujet enfin ce sujet est préoccupant
c'est à dire que
si on ne peut plus manifester dans notre
pays sans qu'à un moment donné il y a
des débordements c'est un problème et
donc c'est normal que nous dans la
représentation nationale la commission
des lois faisons le travail d'A du
ministre pour avoir un certain nombre
d'éléments ça me semble important je
remarque quand même que toute une partie
des manifestations durant toute la
période ce sont très bien passé c'est
les mêmes forces de l'ordre donc vous
voyez bien qu'il y a quelque chose aussi
qui s'est passé qui fait que si
aujourd'hui il y a des violences c'est
que il y a eu un changement d'attitude
question courte réponse courte à quand
la sortie de crise
erwana j'aimerais bien demain matin moi
en me levant j'adorerais et qu'on passe
à des sujets qui sont justement les
sujets qui à mon avis sont les sujets
qui doivent nous préoccuper la santé
l'éducation la transition écologique
j'aimerais bien que ça soit demain matin
et là ça ne sera pas demain matin j'ai
bien peur merci
député du Finistère Quimperlé Concarneau
tout à fait juste président de la
commission des lois d'être venu ici même
dans le 18/20 France Info merci
[Musique]